vincent tu sûreté évidemment extrêmement
abattu par la mort de christophe qui a
été soudaine et c'est vrai que c'est un
immense joueur c'est un gars qu'on adore
a eu la chance de rencontrer une fois
ces voix là c'était 1 6 et 1 c'est un
mythe
bien sûr c'est un milk shake a tué tous
l'origine ferrand sa rancune parfois
parfois t'es pas courage et au départ et
houthaifa rempart des mecs parler d'un
parité de ce genre de joueurs ça te
donne des forces à peu des joueurs qui
étaient hors normes au niveau du jeu
avec un gabarit comme tout un peu moyen
mais qu avec dynamisme et un courage je
m'appelle il était capable en défense de
retourner n'importe où qui la rentrée
souviendra de de l'effet contre tourne à
l'omc est un monstre qui permit l'odeur
qui étaient prêtes pourquoi elle avait
calé à deux miles heure justement
regarde on là ce soir on voulait le
mettre ce soir c'était en demi finale de
la coup du monde 99 face aux all blacks
c'est etc mais c'est vrai que c'était un
gymnase un sens exceptionnel de la
vitesse au rugby c'est une chose mais
faut être capable de tout a vous d
appliquer des frais 80 kg il se jeter
dans les roues du camion tout d'abord
aucune peur avec intel troupeau de
bisons qui arrivent et être capable de
se jeter au milieu compliqué tout le
monde il était peu après c'était autre
chose c'est un camarade en perthois le
l'étude quand on défend parle de
l'argent de phosphore et tout ça mais
tous les sports sont qu'un de solidifier
peu certaines des craintes de bons et
lui et lui était vraiment mdl leader
dans le talent est leader et tout le
monde l'écouté il était un beau un bon
mec et mbanga m'intéresse vraiment alors
selon la sp s'agirait d'un suicide
ça m'a encore plus peiné quand j'ai
quand j'ai appris ça parce que c'est
vrai que vraiment il respirait la joie
de vivre
christophe dominici et tu savais toi
vincent qui voilà qui avaient des ddd
des soucis ou pas du tout eu la brique
sommes nous vraiment aujourd'hui est
tombé non je suis trop content quand
j'ai appris qu'il se suicidait de
l'entente du que que que je suis tombé
des nues à 48 hommes pour irakia
comme je suis j'ai hurlé au téléphone il
ya quelques jours
promène toi et donc je suis tombé des
nues après c'était un gamin quitté un
port de transit et turbulences et à la
turbulence et je savais que parfois il a
visé est conçu si dans sa tête mais
comme beaucoup de joueurs quand ils
arrêtent donc parfois des soucis après
c'est difficile de deux noeuds toujours
de penser au pire d'une bille n'y pense
jamais tu t'es toute l'âme surprise peux
te dire bombe et cela il va tout ça il
va pas très bien où est notre voix par m
mais jamais tu pense au pire toi c'est
le pire tu te ne l'imaginent jamais
c'est un homme comme peu le font mais
cas est qu'à la joie que les cadets
capacité à être enthousiasme dans
l'asile à la bouche et de la vie comme
s'il en pleuvait toi et donc donc tu
t'attends pas si surpris alors après
qu'il ait des soucis on a tous des
soucis mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait des soucis
il y avait des grosses j'ai l'impression
des femmes et la ce on ne peut pas se
mettre à faire passer aux joueurs moi je
me rendais pas compte peu de moi je suis
pas rendu compte
vincent je voulais être remerciés
d'avoir que nous parler ce soir chez une
grosse pensée bien sûr pour la famille
de christophe bouvet ce jour pour violon
et pour mon ami bien sûr bernard laporte
qui est il par un mois de sa fille le
parrain de sa fille et qui est à mon ami
bernard vous le savez qui a été
extrêmement touché n'a même pas pu
s'exprimer aujourd'hui à berlin après
avoir appris là la disparition de deux
mondes vincent je t'aime fourrure est
sûr c'est que c'est dur on est on est là
on soutient fond je sais que c'est dur
pour toi et je les remercie d'avoir été
là bon vin sans vraiment je fais des
membres à bisous et je t'aime fort mon
bain sans merci